Darla what's going on? Why you asking me?
Freddie Freeman, this guy taught me
everything I know about being a dope
superhero true story you should get some
pointers from him what's going on my
best bud in the whole world and also new
kids that I'm meeting for the first time
but seem very cool uh-huh I invited
another friend I hope that's okay
Go back one.
...according to sources
close to the scene an armed man has
taken people hostage on the second floor
of that building the situation is
considered active police say the man is
wearing body armor and should be
considered extremely dangerous no...
I think we just found something we can
agree on...we are following it closely
though... we're going to go play outside
now Rosa...
About time someone listens to me! Stay warm, put your coats on!
Superman it!
Shazam!
Hi everyone it's charlie they just
released Shazam on digital you probably
heard the director talk about their
deleted scene with Henry Cavill Superman
the original ending of the movie
they're now three different endings that
this movie had including the one that
you just saw was Superman walking up and
just freaking Freddie out so we'll break
it down I'll also talk a little bit
about what just happened with the flash
movie because it was some really big
news that just dropped we're doing a new
IMAX ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Suzanne or Superman comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this alternate endings first so there
are two alternate versions of the ending
scene that you just saw deleted scenes
basically the first deleted scene is the
Shazam family seeing that there's a
hostage crisis downtown of the local
news and decided to use their powers to
save the day it's meant to be their
first real time acting as superheroes
after the events of the movie after they
put the seven deadly sins back in the
rock of eternity after dr. sivana goes
to prison and has that scene with mr.
mind this is well after the events of
the movie like okay we're going to be doing
this all the time now at least locally
because even though the Superman scene
as it exists right now is shot so that
you can't see his head it's still meant
to be the real Superman within the
context of the DC Universe meaning that
Billy has met the Justice League and the
Justice League including Superman know
that there are now six kids little kids
mostly crazy strong magical powers
living in Philadelphia if you were the
Justice League or even just Superman you
would probably want to keep tabs on them
because his weakness is their power
magic is his big weakness so I think the
idea is that the Billy has met the
Justice League and they've told him to
take it slow friendly neighborhood
spider-man style while he and the other
Shazam family the Shazam Lee are still
figuring out their powers and learning
about the rock of eternity the reason
that they tried this version of the
ending I obviously wound up deleting it
because they decided the Superman cameo
when wounded up being better this is
because originally there was a separate
Henry Cavill Superman scene that didn't
seem like they were going to be able to
shoot so during the commentary track of
the movie the director said that he
needed to come up with anything oh my
god we have to have an ending for this
movie but he just decided that this
wasn't quite the one that he was looking
for so that's why it wound up being a
big deleted scene the other deleted
scene is the
original ending as they intended the
very first one that they planned with
Superman full on it was a much longer
version of the Superman scene that you
saw in the actual theatrical cut the
deleted scene the alternate ending was
Superman was going to be Henry Cavill
Superman walking into the lunchroom on
cue and sitting down and fully in frame
next to Freddie at the table so that you
could actually see that it was him but
he didn't have any big dialogue there
weren't any lies he just sat down when
Freddy craps his pants and makes that
Yelp sound of extreme surprise
originally he had a bunch of lines where
he starts freaking out and it was a much
longer version of him going oh my god I
have so many questions and just laying
into Superman like a Superman fanboy at
a convention meet-and-greet the reason
why henry cavill didn't wind up in the
theatrical cut of the movie that
original ending was because he was held
up filming mustache and possible fallout
originally what was supposed to happen
is is that Mission Impossible was
supposed to finish their filming by the
time that they started filming the
Shazam movie but Tom Cruise broke his
leg doing that crazy building jump stunt
and they had to delay filming on Mission
Impossible for eight weeks so when they
came back to finish filming Mission
Impossible they had already ready to
film Henry Cavill Superman scene for the
Shazam ending so that's why they had to
come up with a completely different
version of the scene the Justice League
reshoots didn't get in the way those
were actually finished by the time
Shazam started shooting so if you want
to blame someone for Henry Cavill not
being in the Shazam movie blame Tom
Cruise's broken leg the reason why they
couldn't get Henry Cavill in during the
Shazam reshoots which happened way later
at the end of 2018 was that by the time
they had started doing those he was
full-on shooting The Witcher series for
Netflix they're actually dropping a
trailer for that in a couple weeks at
Comic Con so we'll be talking about
Witcher stuff in a couple weeks
normally if there's a small cameo scene
like that it's a lot easier to schedule
around a really big actors other
projects because they're usually filming
big movies all year long they're booked
years and years in advance but it just
wound up being the perfect storm between
moustache and possible Justice League
reshoots in The Witcher series
so that's why you didn't see Henry
Cavill in the Shazam movie so don't be
surprised if you see way bigger cameos
in the next Shazam movie whatever they
call the sequel Justice League
characters like Wonder Woman and
Superman because that gray Levi did say
that they were trying to
get a Wonder Woman cameo in the first
Shazam movie but by the time they
started working on that gal gadot was
also busy doing other stuff biggest
cameo and the Shazam sequel probably
going to be the Rock's Black Adam though
because the Black Adam movie is actually
going to premiere before the Shazam sequel
so we'll have already met that character
and know how he works so it would make
sense that they start to try to get him
into the Shazam movies by that time
moving into the flash movie news you
probably heard that they revealed they
just hired a new director who's actually
a horror director and a new writer they
have not fired
Ezra Miller surprisingly that was the
one thing I felt like was going to
happen but they did throw out the script
that he was working on with Grant
Morrison what happened was is that the
directors of the movie were going to be
the writers from spider-man homecoming
they wanted to do a lighter movie a la
Back to the Future
Ezra Miller wanted to do a darker movie
more like comic book flashpoint and he
wanted to do more multiverse stuff so
they had a couple of competing versions
of the movie Warner Brothers throughout
both of those versions so the writers of
spider-man homecoming left the project
they hired the director of it chapter 2
so they hired a horror director meaning
that they want to go with a darker tone
flash movie but they hired the writer of
the birds of prey movie and the
bumblebee movie so just kind of balanced
that idea because bumblebee was not a
dark film and birds of prey even though
it's obviously a little bit darker
doesn't sound like it's going to be
suicide squad level dark the interesting
thing though is is that people who have
actually been seeing birds of prey
footage say that it's a pretty badass
film so if it's getting so much praise
behind the scenes you would think that
they would want to show a teaser off
but I think they're probably going to wait
till October to show the first trailer
from that when the Joker movie premieres
because remember we still have that
rated R Todd Phillips Joker movie with
Joaquin Phoenix coming up later this
year so there'll be more footage for
that before we see the birds of prey
footage but the last we heard about the
flash movie is is they wanted to
introduce the multiverse and even though
it would probably still be a version of
flashpoint it'll still be relatively
self-contained to just flash comic book
characters may be minor cameo - but the
whole thing now is is they're trying to
separate the DC movies even though
they're technically still connected this
is the last thing that Ezra Miller said
about them introducing DC
multiverse though which did kind of get
me excited even though he sounds like he
just took a whole bunch of drugs before
he did this interview we're talking
about sparking a whole new universe
which is it's not just the DC Multiverse
it's also it's the speedster multiverse
and the speedsters are the ones who
connect all of the disparate pieces of
it because Marvel is the universe right
it's just one world and all the same
characters in DC is a multiverse all
these different stories with different
realities different characters and
versions of characters and the
speedsters are the ones who move through
it all they're like the the connecting
bridge between all these different
collage parts and so I'm really
delighted at how focused everyone is on
getting it just right and I'm really
devoted to that as well and I honestly
like we won't make the film unless it's
going to be this consummate beautiful
offering to the to the fans and to
everybody I mean we're just going to make a
fantastic food but we're really focused
on making it this like super gift to DC
fans couple minor issues with that
interview he does kind of get things
wrong about how the Marvel multiverse
works they've already kind of done
multiverse in the Doctor Strange movies
so we'll just pretend like he hasn't
seen all the Marvel movies yet I know
you're all wondering about when the next
actual Man of Steel movie is going to
happen like I said I did a video about
how JJ Abrams has been basically moving
his company into Warner Brothers with
this big five hundred million dollar
deal they're basically paying JJ Abrams
five hundred million dollars to develop
movies and television shows exclusively
for Warner Brothers now that deal is so
big it's probably going to take the rest of
the year to close that which is probably
why you won't hear anything about that
at Comic Con and DC movies are just kind
of skipping comic-con in general odds
are pretty good that he'll wind up doing
the Green Lantern Corps movie or he'll
wind up doing a Man of Steel sequel
he'll probably go for Green Lantern I
think that actually needs more attention
than Man of Steel and maybe you just do
a Superman cameo during that because we
have had a couple really great Superman
films in the last 20-30 years but we
have not had a good Green Lantern movie
yet fun Easter Egg to the director of
Mission Impossible
christopher mcquarrie and henry cavill
actually pitched Green Lantern and
Superman movies to Warner Brothers a
little while ago but he actually said
the director said that they did not go
for it or they did not move forward with
his idea for a Green Lantern movie or
for a Man of Steel sequel he never
explained what the plot of those movies
were supposed to be so it's just open to
speculation as to what those might have
looked like but the way he tells it now
is that he does not expect to do any
kind of superhero movie in the future so
whatever that idea was it sounds like
it's come and gone but if there's any
really big DC movie news happening
around comic-con I will do a video for
it but I'm not expecting any big
trailers the big news though is is
Marvel just announced they're doing a
90-minute Hall H comic-con panel with
Kevin Feige that means they're probably
going to show off footage for a couple
films maybe some concept art and
announced their phase 4 schedule or at
least in as four years or so worth of
movies including spider-man 3 so I will
talk about all that stuff in a separate
video but if you have any big questions
that you want me to make bonus videos
about just let me know in the comments
and congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video comical
Cosme please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my spider-man far from home
Easter eggs and post credit scene
videos and click here for that new
Shazam Black Adam scene thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!